buonasera a tutti eheheh sono
ricercatore del consiglio
nazionale delle ricerche
e lavoro in un istituto d
scienze e tecnologie dei
materiali ceramici compositi che
ha sede a faenza
sono venuta qui
con il mio cranio vi prometto
che non vi reciterò
l'amleto di shakespeare
ma ti parlerò di materiali per
la medicina rigenerativa
attività che svolgo con un
gruppo di giovani molto motivati
che fanno parte del mio gruppo e
che vedete qui
le incarti
la medicina rigenerativa per
lavorare a un forte impatto
seu molte delle hackyour gr
pelle in particolare la
chirurgia ortopedica
la neurochirurgia la trilogia
maxillo-facciale dentale
è ormai sotto gli occhi di
tutti che lo stile di vita e
invecchiamento della nostra
società
hanno creato un impatto molto
negativo sulle
patologie che riguardano
l'apparato muscolo-scheletrico
in particolare le cause possono
essere di carattere traumatico
oh the generativo come le
infezioni croniche le malattie
tumorali
in tutti questi casi
il chirurgo si in sala
operatoria si trova a far fronte
alla mancanza di tessuto
sia che inizi asporti una
porzione
per ragioni degenerative
operatori traumatiche
ora il tessuto osseo è uno dei
pochissimi tessuti
eheh del nostro organismo anche
in grado si di riparare una
frattura
ma non è in grado di rigenerare
anpi e porzioni di se stesso
porzioni massive
pertanto il chirurgo si trova
davanti all'impossibilità
di far fronte a questa mancanza
di tessuto
se non lo è attraverso
l'utilizzo di impianti ossei
cioè intelaiature
tridimensionali
che here noi dobbiamo progettare
in modo tali
in modo tale che le cellule
lun riconoscano aderiscono a
questo impianto
di prolific i know
e rigenerano
per pian piano il tessuto
mancante
sia digerendo rimpianto hey
rigenerando lo
o anche lasciando il sito ma il
nostro target e quello di fare
scomparire completamente
l'impianto ostro
e quindi di creare un ponte
nuovo
dove era lo spazio
diciamo del tessuto mancante
formato
esattamente identico allo stesso
tessuto osseo mancante
eheh
le problematiche più frequenti
è come abbiamo detto sono
relative alle ossa lunghe per
ragioni traumatiche pensate al
numero enorme di incidenti
dovute ahahah deformità dello
scheletro
eh sono e diciamo problematiche
relative alle ossa piatte
e' il caso della delle nostre
del cranio
oggi
non so se tutti siete a
conoscenza del fatto che per
qualunque trauma cranico di una
entità
sopra la valore medio quindi
medio alta
il chirurgo
asportano per collo cranico
e non si aspetta un certo tempo
e' necessario per la
decompressione dei ematomi
dell'ematoma del centro e dei
centri nervosi
quindi non si fa più come una
volta in quel paziente veniva
tenuto ris aspettava vedere che
cosa succederà che cosa a che
cosa avrebbe portato quel trauma
sì apre il cranio e si aspetta
la decompressione per evitare
lesione dei centri nervosi
poi questo cranio deve venire
chiuso
ma il nostro osso asportato
non è più in grado di chiudere
la la carità aperta
perchè e va incontro un
processo di riassorbimento
rapido
per cui
il nostro percolo cadrebbe
all'interno
quindi deve essere progettato un
materiale
allo stesso modo
lei e 3 scusate lee è relazione
tutte le problematiche costo
cartilagine
helmut dovute alle elezioni
dell'articolazione del ginocchio
dell'anca
rappresenta una potere gh
estremamente pne frequente
negli sportivi
e anche in tutti diciamo in
tutta la popolazione in una
fascia d'età molto ancora
barsantini individui molto
giovani
tradizionalmente si interveniva
per sgonfiare a tutte queste
problematiche cercando di
risolvere il problema dal punto
di vista funzionale
quindi sono state progettate
delle soluzioni
come vedete qui descritte
placche metalliche gtt grandi
protesi metalliche
nelle acque periodo che va dagli
anni sessanta fino all'inizio
degli anni 90
per tutta bella diciamo la
progettazione delle protesi e
degli impianti e dominata
dalla ricerca sulle plastiche
sì materiali metallici
si pensava a riprodurre
funzionalità del paziente
carige a ripristinare la
non ci si preoccupava di quanto
queste protesi ecco queste
placche metalliche
avrebbero
% avuto che che tipo di impatto
avrebbero avuto sull'organismo
c'è un impatto estremamente
invasivo voi immaginate che per
introdurre una protesi di questo
tipo il chirurgo deve asportare
una porzione molto estesa del
tessuto osseo
oltre a quello già mancante
quindi poiché la durata delle
protesi
e di un tempo limitato non va
oltre i 10 15 anni
se viene protesizzato
l'individuo giovane
questo puoi per dovrà la
protesi dovrà essere
sostituita
il chirurgo si troverà davanti
a un problema doppio di quello
iniziale
illa ricercatore che si occupa
di sviluppo di materiale nella
medicina rigenerativa
re ha pensato di prendere
ispirazione dalla natura
ci sono vari modi con cui questi
amo prendere ispirazione dalla
natura
per in quanto la naturale
pillola un progettista
abilissimo
ha fornito materiali
estremamente
per performanti materiali
multifunzionali capaci di auto
rigenerarsi
e quindi noi possiamo seguire un
approccio
top down e prendere questi
materiali dalla natura come la
natura ci rifornisce
e trasformarli a nostro
piacimento oppure
possiamo copiare dalla natura
con me appunto ingeniere
abilissimo
copiare i processi che la natura
mette in atto
produrre sui materiali
un esempio
d hair
approccio
top down è quello che abbiamo
realizzato nei nostri laboratori
dopo una estensiva ricerca
sulle specie arboree
abbiamo identificato il
materiale
e che si chiama rattan è un
legno che viene utilizzato per
fare sedie da giardino
potete vedere da questa immagine
l'incredibile similitudine
della ratta anna con il tessuto
osseo mano
dove noi riconosciamo questi
canali centrali camping che sono
al centro dell osteone
questi canali a persiane che
trasportano
sata attraverso cui passano
i vasi sanguigni
una serie di strutture
porosa intorno al canale a
veneziano che consente ai fluidi
via l'ossigeno di portare
% diciamo nutrimento le cellule
una struttura lamellare
complessa
che da le proprietà
e meccaniche funzionali al
tessuto osseo
e queste tutte queste
caratteristiche
video struttura gerarchicamente
organizzata dalla mano a lamma
toscana
tipiche del tessuto osseo li
abbiamo ritrovate
nella rattan questo legno
abbiamo quindi pensato
d per mettere a punto un
processo cioè di prenderlo
dalla natura e di trasformarlo
il processo di trasformazione
è un processo chimico multi
startup che parte da una piroli
che come fosse un processo di
fossilizzazione come quando si
trova
un tronco
antico la dignità e che di
milioni di anni che ha questa
caratteristica di essere stato
trasformato
inna carbone e perché viene
trovato già sotto il terreno e
allo stesso modo noi abbiamo
già attuato questo processo che
parte da un film da un processo
di pirrolici
e
otteniamo quindi la
trasformazione della cellulosa
in
unina temp lante in una
struttura abate di carbonio
e cambiamo senza mai modificare
la struttura della panna
cambiamo alla chimica intorno a
questo atomo di carbonio
introduciamo il calcio elemento
fondamentale l'ossigeno il
carbonato di fosfato
alla fine abbiamo tenuto
lo stesso rapallo stessa
struttura tridimensionale
gerarchicamente organizzata
con la composizione chimica
dell'idrossido appetite
la fase minerale costituente
l'80 % in peso del tessuto osseo
umano
adesso vediamo un filmato che ci
mostra come il nostro adia
questa struttura tridimensionale
gerarchicamente organizzata
molto difficile da riprodurre
il laboratorio
facile da trovare in natura
e quindi avendo la struttura
vedete riprodotta in quest'ora
tanto non possiamo trattare la
chimicamente senza alterare
la morfologia
e la struttura complessa derrata
ne vengono utilizzate aderire
rt formichina alta pressione
e art quello che otteniamo alla
fine appunto da dopo questo
trattamento
un cantante
cioè una struttura in carbonio
che mantiene la forma
quell'attimo di carbonio poi
viene trasformato
in idrossiapatite
questi materiali sono già stati
sperimentati sugli animali
gli ultimi animali sono in
questo momento ina s
limentazione all ospedale agli
ospedali ortopedici rizzoli di
bologna
e e sono stati impiantati
in un difetto critico sulla
pecora
cosa vuol dire critico cioè
questo materiale è stato
progettato per per far fronte
alla problematica
di mancanza
d segmenti lunghi per la
sostituzione di ossa lunghe
portanti carico che hanno quindi
una struttura
per cui la biomeccanica
dell'osso
verrà rispettata durante il
processo di
rigenerazione ossea
la vedete ella controllo
radiografico per ora è stato
ottimo
e la istologia che vedete
riportata qui
fa vedere che il materiale
è stato completamente
rigenerato da tessuto osseo
nuovo
pensate quindi all'impatto
quando questo materiale entrerà
nei test clinici
subito dopo la fine dei test
animali passerà alla clinica
l'impatto che potrà avere un
materiale di questo genere che
vedete inserita in un femore
della donna che sta correndo
rispetto
a placche metalliche
chiodi
che non verranno mai più tolti
nel caso di
mancanza di un lungo segmento
postino
passiamo invece ho un esempio d
approccio
bottom up
dove invece noi prendiamo un
processo che la natura
mette in atto è quello che il
processo di dio mineralizzazione
che la natura acqua all'interno
del nostro organismo per
generare il tessuto osseo
il tessuto osseo eccomi ho detto
un tipico esempio di dio
mineralizzazione su un cantante
organico che in questo caso il
collagene
quel collagene fa da base
mentre si forma il collagene
dalla mano fibra la macro fibra
in tessuto a formare un tessuto
contemporaneamente avviene la
deposizione di nano nuclei di
trost epatite
danno forza estructura
a questo collagene
abbiamo quindi
tentato di rifare
questo processo in laboratorio e
come vedete ci siamo riusciti
abbiamo prodotto un materiale
composito
completamente analogo
al tessuto osso naturale
avendo raggiunto questo target
abbiamo pensato che allora
potevamo anche riprodurre emp
delle regioni anatomiche
multifunzionali
come per esempio
la regione poste o cartilaginea
cioè l'articolazione
dove abbiamo collagene
mineralizzato che forma la
porzione a ostia la fase
minerale diminuisce gradualmente
fino arrivare alla cartilagine
che altri non è che collageno
quindi abbiamo pensato possiamo
produrre un materiale
a gradiente
con posizionale morfologico e
così
abbiamo fatto
abbiamo tentato di riprodurre
l'osso
e la cartilagine mineralizzate e
quindi lo strato cartilagineo
senza fase minerale
questa web
alla vostra reading destra
vedette la nostro materiale alla
sinistra una regione
osteocondrale naturale
il materiale
è stato l'ho sperimentato
per sull'uomo già per piede in
uno studio multicentrico in
tutti gli ospedali d'europa
come vedete abbiamo un materiale
tristrato
che mimma l'osso la cartilagine
mineralizzata che la cartilagine
soprastante
in caso di lesioni non troppe
spese fino a un massimo di 4
centimetri quadrati
la missione sia essa
osteoartrite dissecante sia essa
una lesione dovuta trauma
sportivo
eliminata
con un intervento
come vedete in questo filmato
e here
melania rea -
eheh presentata in maniera
geometrica
cosicché
hillary nostro materiale
con delle semplici forbici
chirurgiche può essere tagliato
corrispondentemente
emesso nella visione
le cellule
denicar dovute al sanguinamento
che passano
hair add al sangue subcondrale
verso lo stato cartilagineo
saranno in grado
di differenziarsi
i'm tessuto osseo nella parte
bassa per semplice informazione
chimica
hey inna struttura cartilaginea
nella parte alta
avremo quindi la completa il
completo ripristino
riad e lira regione costo
condrale
e la cura nel tempo nel tempo di
circa 3 mesi
la completa ricostruzione dei
tessuti occhio
e cartilagine
la istologia dimostra che c'è
completa rigenerazione
di osso edicart i lati
ovviamente l'impatto che questo
materiale può avere evidente
qui vedete le protesi
tradizionali
l'acquisizione di di questo
femore dentro cui deve entrare
un infimo lo metallico di circa
20 centimetri
quindi tutto questo scompare
e abbiamo come vedete
nell'immagine
alla vostra destra
unina
materiale molto piccolo
che con me una mosaico plastica
già a sostituire la lesione
e qui vedete l'immagine della
lesione ostia ti cartilaginea
completamente ripristinata
di un paziente senti diciamo
curato qui all ospedale
ortopedico rizzoli
pretty questi materiali è
eheh una ali un album
photo è nato sede staccata dal
nostro gruppo di ricercatori ha
creato un impresa
aika aika nel mondo bio medicale
questa impresa si chiama
finceramica sega a faenza
ed è diventata leader mondiale
nella riparazione del trasimeno
come egli ha spiegato prima per
te occorre progettare materiali
per la ripresa dei cani in tutti
i casi in cui siamo sport
asportazione del opercolo
cranico o per trauma proprio
della the happy capranica
e l dal atac del paziente
abbiamo ehm la immagine
l'attacca diene inviata i
lavoratori e sulla tattica
viene realizzato il presto il
pezzo mancante grazie a un
processo di rapid prototyping
che vedete qui nell'immagine
illa materiale viene
riconosciuto come proprio in
quanto
riproduce la morfologia
e la struttura e la composizione
dell'osso kimmich dell'orso
umano
quindi le cellule
dalla teca passano all'impianto
fiorillo rigenerano riformando
corso autologo cioè l'osto del
paziente
quindi nel giro di un anno
l'impianto sto è scomparso e
abbiamo costo del paziente
vedete nell immagine
radiografica la perfetta
continuità tra la protesi e la
tecnica
lultima
cosa di cui voglio parlare per
larghi è l' ultima delle
innovazioni che abbiamo
realizzato che quella di
sostituire
piccole concentrazioni di calcio
dei nostri impianti ossei
condivisioni ferro
questo fanno hair
fanno che inducono
un'altra capacità super
paramagnetica
nell'impianto ostia che abbiamo
progettato questo vuol dire che
quell'impianto ostia sarà in
grado di rispondere a campi
magnetici esterni anche molto
bassi quindi quell'impianto
funzionerà come una stazione in
vivo
controllabile dall esterno
quindi opposto aumentare
fortemente attivando l'impianto
con dei campi magnetici la
capacità di rigenerazione del
mio impianto dai 6 mesi
posso ridurre
probabilmente in 2 mesi o meno
grazie a un processo di richiamo
di attivazione dei fattori di
crescita dei fattori vascolari
non solo
abbiamo già verificato e lo
vedete in questa istologia
che l'ho sto possiamo indurre la
formazione di aosto
lamellare orientato
e quindi aumentare è fortemente
le proprietà biomeccaniche di
quel tessuto candia maris
generare e da ultimo forse un
sogno potremmo %
progettare degli impianti hi fi
fattori esterni in maniera pc
e ovviamente
all'utilizzo di viti
chiodi che nella prima fase di
rigenerazione
siamo costretti a mettere per
tenere fermo l'impianto
vi lascio the ring a te vi
saluto
vi lascio con questa frase di
siena e kate che pur essendo
stata scritta 2000 anni fa e'
sicuramente molto attuale nel
mondo della ricerca grazie